how do I get people to the YouTube
channel like how do they know it even
exists YouTube takes the most time to
build but is the most long-term brand
building that you can do because YouTube
is the only place where your videos will
live forever in a year nobody will care
what happens on your Instagram inside
every video should be a call to action
to get something free first chapter of
your book for free bonus video about the
eight sales techniques that can blow up
your business how I became a millionaire
before 30 like whatever bonuses fit best
and you put it in the middle of the
video not at the beginning not at the
end but in the middle of the video that
then leads people to a landing page and
then you get their email address because
it's great to build a YouTube channel
but I want you to have a business that's
successful on top of it not just your
goal isn't to just be an influencer
right yeah absolutely so we need to get
people off of YouTube onto uh onto our
email list and then when your book comes
out then you've got a list to be able to
pitch people too
I'm very successful realtor and I
had started having people ask me to
coach them and help them and and really
spend some time in the lockdown thinking
about what the next step is in my
journey and
um I this year I decided I wanted to be
a speaker author coach so I'm writing a
book
um I've
um just got certified as a high
performance coach with Brendan's Group
which is how I found you by the way cool
and I'm just thinking about how do I
launch a thought leader career
um I fell in love with doing videos I do
listing videos that sell houses and
really love being in front of the camera
it turns out and so yeah so I'm super
pumped about building I've got a um here
in Denver I have a Denver office and a
boulder office but in this office I've
already built out a little maybe it's 12
by 12 room for a studio all right I have
gear purchased I have no excuses
um just learning how to get it all set
up I have acoustic tiles on the walls I
have lighting on the way you know I'm
doing the whole thing and um what I'm
really hoping to do is put out video
content
um to start to build first of all
momentum from my book
um I was a millionaire before I was 30
and then I was homeless for six years as
a drug addict so um I have and I've been
clean for 12 years now so I have a you
know I have a little bit of a journey to
share with people and
um really interested in helping people
you know like you mentioned in your book
you know help you people who've been
doing the same thing but the same thing
in my case might mean somebody who's
struggling to make it as a realtor it
might mean somebody who's been homeless
it might mean somebody is a drug addict
you know all of those people are in my
core group of people to help whether
they're Realtors or
entrepreneurs I want to help them build
a business the way that I was able to
build a business which was really
focusing on the heart rather than the
mind so instead of top of mind
um I'm all about top of heart which is
all about making real emotional
connections with people so I'm babbling
but the the point of our time together
here is I'm really excited to learn from
you uh I have a fear and uh that fear is
that is not to do video my fear is that
it is mediocrity
um my fear is that um you know I've I've
had some friends start YouTube channels
or put out videos and I watched them put
out you know a video five six seven
times and they go away and never do it
again because it's terrible because
there's nobody looking there's nobody
watching and I'm I'm a I'm a um a high
achiever and uh I expect big things and
I'm afraid that I'm going to start
putting out video nobody's going to
watch and I'm going to go away so what I
need is a plan to stick to and if you
tell me do x amount of videos this often
for this long
um no matter what I'll do it
um but that's that's where I need is I
need some help with how to get started
great and and the target's going to be
real estate or or no anybody anybody
who's in sales or or marketing so really
which is you know an entrepreneur or
sales people I think that immediately uh
I can impact Realtors you know um if a
realtor hears that I've done 50 million
in real estate this year they'll want to
learn from me so I have a really good
soft you know audience right away
um and I have some people that kind of I
believe will follow what I do there but
I want to I don't want to limit it to
this real estate
got it so I would create a plan that
I would execute for all of 2021
and and you're not allowed to deviate
from it until you get to 2022. yeah
instead of judging like is it working or
not because it because YouTube
especially takes the most time to build
but is the most long-term brand building
that you can do because YouTube
is the only place where your videos will
live forever
right so we'll post you know this as an
IG live is great without some people
watching you see a couple some people
watching the replay but you know in in a
year nobody will care what happens on
your Instagram
five days later nobody cares what's
happened on your Instagram but if you're
if you're a fan of Brandon's work you
know his black and white video series
six years later are still getting views
still getting attention still getting
interest especially if the if the
content you can talk about is Evergreen
and timeless
so if you're talking about sales
principles as opposed to selling in
December 2020 sure right so I want
Evergreen kind of content and you can
definitely dive into elements of your
story I think that's fantastic
um three videos a week
you can fill them all on one day if you
can get to daily that's awesome but but
uh if you're a high achiever we need to
be over one one a week three would be my
kind of minimum in
um you can fill them all on one day if
you want you know for for a couple weeks
at a time so you don't have to
go into the studio or you know three
times a week
um I wanna uh talking head video
so you talking direct the camera and you
can you can pull ideas from whoever you
think is your biggest kind of
contemporary in the YouTube world and
it's probably a mix of people there's
nobody there's no one person who's like
you so I'd pull topics from Brendan I
pull topics from my channel I pull
topics from in sales I'd be looking at
Grant Cardone I've been looking at
Jordan Belfort if you're looking at
Robert Kiyosaki if you're looking at
like whoever are the
your your bits of all these different
people go to their channels look at the
most successful videos that they've ever
done and then make your version of it
and don't don't even care what they I
don't care what they said so you can go
to Brendan's Channel or garyvee's
Channel and it's you know the advice
every 20 year old needs to hear
I want you to make that video
without watching what their advice is I
don't care what Brendan's advice is I
want grants advice so focus on the topic
take the title and take the topic
okay 10 minute plus video
damn it what
to sound so long it's okay I'm just
being honest you could you could do it
because you've you you've got knowledge
to share sure yeah I babbled at you for
10 minutes already so I'm in yeah well
Babylon is different than 10 minutes
right sure yeah yeah in in the book
there's there's the structure of how to
do a perfect thought leadership yeah
piece of content I would hone in on that
I I would guess you would be great at
your storytelling
you could easily tell a three four five
minute story or more your story client
story uh somebody you've mentored
um something you see happening with
young real estate agent sales people
addicts like there's lots of stories you
could tell I think you'd be great at
that I think the Practical advice piece
you'd probably be great at that too so
okay to solve this problem do one two
three step one do this and I'm sure you
could you've just had enough experience
you can you can even you had a point
form you could talk to those points and
be eloquent in in tons of value where
most people struggles is the opening
so you got to hit me with something that
you believe that that most people would
find different or weird
um so even as practice like what's one
thing you believe grant that other
people don't believe uh lead generation
is
great so like that's the first thing out
of your face when you press record yeah
the very first thing right so when I
work with people then they they still
press record and say hey it's welcome
back it's me Grant like no crap yeah
right so you press a chord and like the
very first thing has to be a powerful
opinion that
like what did he just say yeah and so
that that takes some training to do but
I think most of the other stuff you'll
be great at
um so at least one video a week of the
three that is thought leadership like
that direct the camera talking uh I
would love to see one of the three be a
coaching video
okay where there's somebody in front of
you like this this is a coaching video
right but flipped so so now you're
coaching somebody who is in your office
is part of your fan group
um is an up and coming sales person is
an addict or is an addict recovery or
any of the topics that you deal with
okay and
the great part about that is you just
have to show up
there's no script there's no memorizing
anything there's no what's my first
sentence it's it's you just coaching
your your preparation is the Decades of
experience you have in this business
helping people so my goal let me
interrupt you real quick my goal is to
build a bit of a membership site and to
uh group coaching for certified high
performance so I think you've talked
about it this before so you maybe take a
snippet of somebody who's
um you know maybe there's a Facebook
maybe we have a zoom call once a month
um and I do some one-on-one in front of
everybody else for 15-20 minutes taking
a piece of that and just putting that as
YouTube content you know with their
permission of course you can do that
um and or you could do this okay where
you do it over something like Instagram
live to help build your Instagram
audience up or it could just be a
separate Zoom that you do either for
pain members so hey as a bonus you also
get a one-on-one with Grant okay right
so if you sorry sorry interrupt you but
then do you take this and put it back
into YouTube meaning yes okay uh because
that not all of these like I have a
Daily Show here not all of them get cut
for YouTube some of them if it's really
good it'll get cut my team just decides
that which one goes up
um but yeah so I go live daily on
Instagram uh and that helps the
Instagram audience and also creates
content for other potential platforms I
mean this this could get cut up into a
million different ways for different
platforms depending on what comes out of
it
um but that you could have it as a bonus
so hey here's my membership and it costs
x per month but if you sign up for the
annual deal you also get a one-on-one
with Grant
that then can be turned into content
right so you use it to you can use it to
get people into your program
um if you love it and you want to do
more of it then
uh maybe you have enough members to to
back it up if not then you can do it for
free
and people get to see you coaching so
that if it's free then it's public if
it's free then it's going to be online
and some people may not want it to be
public so say okay great well I've got a
I've got a coaching package and I've got
my membership program where you can
train with me every two weeks sure right
so the free gives you the attention that
then shows off you as a coach because if
you want to sell a membership program
where you're going to be coaching people
I need to see you as a coach
right not just a thought leader talking
the camera I need to see you like get
get the Ugg bug eyes like oh my God
grant I can't believe what you just said
that saved my life right yeah
um and it's fun you know it's fun like
talking to a person not just like camera
inside a 12x12 little studio right yeah
um and then my third series would be
something around the book
so how many chapters are in the book
um 15 16. yeah so I would take that and
to turn those into 15 to 16. uh
regular themes okay but then you cycle
through
so like what's chapter one in the book
um
I don't know whatever chapter seven and
I haven't thought like the one I'm
writing right now is called scraping the
bottom so it's about hitting rock bottom
and just kind of getting dragged along
the bottom perfect instead of bouncing
off it yeah and what what chapter number
is that a seven seven perfect so seven
is scraping the bottom and so you know
every 15 16 weeks
there's going to be another video about
scraping the bottom got it and then you
just tell a different story right you've
got lots of different stories that you
can relate to you clients in the news
cycle about scraping the bottom
because I want you creating content that
relates to the book okay and then inside
those videos you can say hey and this is
also chapter seven
in my book right and it builds awareness
for the book uh without it being a hey
go buy my book kind of sales pitch every
time got it
um inside so those those would be my
three series that I would start with
that's awesome direct the camera where
you're pulling from the people who you
kind of look up to and respect uh
coaching with people who are in your
community uh and then a series around
the book
inside every video should be a call to
action to get something free first
chapter of your book for free uh bonus
video about the eight sales techniques
that can blow up your business
Howard became a millionaire before 30
like whatever whatever bonuses uh fit
best and you put it in the middle of the
video not at the beginning not at the
end but in the middle of the video
that then leads people to a landing page
and then you get their email address
because it's great to build a YouTube
channel but I want you to have a
business that's successful on top of it
not just your goal isn't to just be an
influencer right yeah absolutely so we
need to get people off of YouTube onto
uh onto our email list and then when
your book comes out then you've got a
list to be able to pitch people to
um if you want to add a fourth Series in
it would be interviews
okay
where you would try to get uh
Grant Cardone and Jordan Belfort and
Brandon burchard and whoever on the
channel do interviews and then you can
run targeted ads against their channel
to kind of hack Their audience to get
them to come on board
um even this like you could take this
interview this one-on-one
and turn it into a YouTube video and
then run it as a targeted ad against my
audience
so then people who know me they'll click
on it because they know me and then
they'll say who's this grant guy and
they learn about you and then dive down
your Channel
um if you want to add a fourth series
and then if you if you wanted to make
more then I would double down on one of
those other series I wouldn't double
down the book but I would double down on
either the coaching or the direct the
camera
yeah if you want to go two a week on one
of those now we're talking four or five
videos a week
um again depends on how
committed UI and how serious you want to
take it but at least three of those
videos per week for all of 2021 and then
evaluate how we're doing at the end of
the year just like your mindset is where
I'm doing this three videos a week for
the entire year not oh I'm quitting in
February because exactly right yeah
that's exactly my fear how do I get
people to the YouTube channel like how
do they know it even exists right
because they're a gazillion YouTube
channels how does that
yeah so starting point one we're picking
good titles that are coming from other
channels right so that video on
Brendan's Channel about advice I give to
people in my 20s for example
um you may not ever have thought of that
as a title but you could give you could
make that video you know you could you
can come up with so we're pulling good
titles already the ultimate hope is to
show up as suggested against those
people's channels
um but Step One is picking great topics
that people care about because a lot of
times you might think oh I'm gonna make
a video on lead generation
but instead of calling it maybe using
the words lead generation sucks on
YouTube
maybe it's how to get more sales right
and so the content can be exactly the
same yeah but how you title it can make
a world of difference for how that video
performs that's huge um two do you have
an email list
no nothing zero okay so you know we got
to start building an email list yeah
yeah and anytime you come with a new
video or a series of videos you email
them the video so people can find it and
I should I shouldn't say zero you know I
have 150 people who saw me on stage
right before kovid and are really eager
to do something with me and I've done
zero with that so great this is you know
it's time yeah hey the first 150 is the
hardest so yeah I got 150. yeah you send
them links to the videos as they come up
um even better if you can put them
inside a playlist
okay uh the link goes into a playlist
yeah I'm going to show you how I'm going
to show you a hot Grant this is great
let me show I'm going to go to my
computer I'm going to show you this
right now this is what you're gonna have
to do when you put out all your videos
okay so we're gonna go to Brendan's
channel so we've got the videos here uh
and say this one says generate energy in
your life okay like say this is your
video yeah okay
when you load the video here there's an
ID up here okay it's gonna go
youtube.com watch
question mark V equals and then this is
the ID of that video okay okay that's
the video ID
why this is so important is we're going
to go back to Brandon's Channel we're
going to click upload so we're going to
click
play all
and then this code we need to pull from
your list so up here you only have to do
this once once you get this code
we're going to take this says and list
equals
this giant thing okay
I'm going to copy that
okay then we're going back to his video
here
if I paste this at the end of this list
at the end of that link it's going to
paste it
what's going to happen is it still shows
me the video
but now on the side it's inside of a
playlist wow so what's going to happen
is it says 284 videos
so you share this video
and then automatic is going to run
through 284 other videos from his
channel right and so if you only have
five videos it'll only show five videos
right but as you keep adding to it it's
going to keep adding more and more and
more and more videos in WoW
some people load the video and then just
turn it off like or they don't turn off
the computer but they go for lunch or
something and they come back oh I just
ended up watching 30 of Grant's videos
in the background yeah which all helps
with the outgoing people find out about
it that's incredible incredible now you
can also do this with other any video on
YouTube so this is this is um
okay let me find like uh let's go Grant
Cardone another Grant
so if I go to Grant Cardone
and we pull up this thing he did about
real estate predictions
so this is the video if you wanted to
share this video
you could take grants video
put the same Link at the end
and then it's going to put it inside
Brendan's playlist
oh wow so after Grant's video is done
we're going to watch 284 of Brendan
burchard videos wow so for you if you
want to share my video or garyvee video
or this inspirational video that you
found that's not yours
you then add your code at the end of it
and when that video finishes it'll just
auto start playing all of your videos
afterwards that's amazing
you seem to get that link once like that
link that I copied was Brendan's link
right you got to get your link once you
have your channel we can set that up and
if you forget I can I can help you again
to do it but
um
yeah it's like a quick little setup and
then you put that at the end of any
video that you're going to share if
you're just send it to one person and
look look what I did actually I just
left my computer and the brand video is
still playing
right so I'm gonna end up watching like
40 Brendan Bouchard videos because I
forgot that I left it open which that
helps again with the YouTube algorithm
um if you send it to one person it
doesn't matter like don't worry about
adding the code if you just send it to
your friend but if you put it into a
newsletter or on social media where
multiple people could be looking at it
it all adds up for the watch time
is you know instead of hitting my
audience over the head with another
email about me I can say you know hey
check out this amazing video from Evan
Carmichael but Carmichael but they end
up going through my videos after that
anyway yeah so yeah yeah that's awesome
and it the link leads them to that video
yeah so they don't have to click
anything else they're still watching
that one video but then at the end all
of a sudden they just get put into the
playlist that's awesome yeah that's
amazing so every time you're sharing in
a newsletter or publicly you want to add
your link
um and then third thing quick is I would
look at if you really want to grow
quickly I would look at a targeted ad
campaign yeah okay if you have a budget
to spend
um against different people's audiences
so on social or on YouTube YouTube okay
uh suggested video so video discovery
this pre-roll and Discovery pre-roll
means it shows up before somebody else's
video you don't want that Discovery
means it'll show up down the side
and so I would look at different videos
going to different people's audiences
okay so anything high performance
we're targeting Brendan's audience
anything real estate we're targeting
grants audience you know anything
failed maybe we're targeting Jordan's
audience or or uh you know like whoever
you think and it's got to be a big
player but if they only have a small
audience it's not worth doing
um
anything entrepreneurship you could
Target my channel my audience and you
don't need access to be able to to do it
like you could just Target my audience
right now with any video that you've got
you just want to be cognizant if you did
a real estate video to my audience it
may not be as good as Grant Cardell
right sure
um and the little bonus on top of that
is if you get an interview with them you
definitely Target Their audience with
with those videos
um so yeah so you're consistently making
content with good titles that attract
attention we're using that link so
anywhere we share it outside of YouTube
we're putting people to a playlist and
then we're running targeted ads
um for each video that goes up with a
goal to gain views and subscribers a lot
of people when they do ads they just
pump up their numbers but it doesn't
convert to subscribers that's not what
we want like you buying a whole bunch
you could buy 40 000 views from somebody
in Argentina and you know great you got
views but it's not actually building
your audience
okay so I'd be looking at USA first but
maybe Canada U.S sorry Canada UK
Australia usually the other three
markets after U.S
um
and then hyper targeted for the video
you're going after again personal
development high performance Brendan you
just pick or Tony Robbins like those
topics you pick and you can just create
different categories like addiction
might be somebody else I don't know who
the who the leading addiction channel
would be
um
yeah so if you've got a budget that's a
faster way to hack the growth
that's amazing that's amazing cool
because I wasn't sure where to put the
video so and then do I take the same
video from YouTube and also put it as a
video blog on my website and It All
Leads back to the same place right you
can if you're gonna put it on your
website I would don't do it as an embed
yeah do it as a oh this is an even bonus
bonus so most people do it as an
embedded link right so you can actually
watch the video on your website
so you can like click play and they're
still on your website yeah don't do that
um YouTube heavily discounts embedded
views they count for almost nothing they
want you on YouTube yeah so what you
should do is have the have a thumbnail
like a big thumbnail to say hey watch
the video with the play button and when
they click it it goes to YouTube
so leave your site and they go to in a
new window and they go to YouTube
and even even extra bonus on top of that
is that link also has your playlist code
at the end yeah
so then they're watching all of your
videos after
and if I made any I can have faith that
they're going to come back to my website
to learn more
because you load it in a new tab
right
yeah so they have to close that Tab and
then there's your website again okay
okay so it's not like they've really
left my site because that's the fear
right
is that okay amazing thank you
that's your 2021 plan sweet thank you
I'm on it I'm building it I'll be you
know yeah I'll be on our um I'll call
and I'll report back I love it all right
grant cheering you on man thank you very
much I appreciate it yeah take care see
ya
I'm not at the beginning of my
entrepreneur Journey okay but I took a
really long break because I wasn't well
and so getting back
into doing it and doing something a
little bit different feels intimidating
and I've been trying to get back for
such a long time that even the thought
even it just gets me like I get
overthink things get caught up my
confidence isn't really great anymore so
that's what I need help with is getting
back and doing things I used to be
really confident and you know doing
things was like oh yeah let's just have
the idea I get it sorted get it out
there and now that doesn't seem to be
happening is in the same way
I hear you
uh I've been I think we've all been on
roller coasters like that's part of the
entrepreneurial journey is the the ups
and downs and ups and downs and the
trick for me at least is anytime I'm in
a low is that should be gentler on
myself
and more kind and not to expect the same
level of output as what I had before
because if I'm living in the pot like if
I'm really down because something
happened to compare myself to Evan from
whatever year when I was crushing it and
ambitious uh it only makes things worse
it only like destroys the confidence
even more as opposed to helping me so
um whether it's a physical like when I
broke my neck in 2019
like I couldn't get out of bed
like sitting up by myself was a win
not not asking my wife Nina to help me
like be my crutch so that I can go pee
was a win right let alone like speaking
and writing books and doing my tour and
like making videos and right like that
was the win just getting up and not
needing help to go to the bathroom was a
win right yeah so I don't know what you
know kind of Health Journey you know
you've been through or coming through
um but it's just being more gentle on
yourself that you did the best you could
with what you had and still are trying
to do the best you can with what you
have and you can get back to where you
were and Beyond uh but it's a process
and it's okay if it's not like tomorrow
that you're not instantly better and
healed and crushing it
yeah yeah I think I think my expectation
always is oh yeah today's the day
that it's gonna all be okay and
everything's gonna like met it's been a
long time like many years so it's been
like I think
uh where's the word like logistically
like you know like in my head I want to
be like this
and my body's like well we're still not
there yet and um so yeah so there's like
there is a bit of that expectation and
then it just kind of turns into but I'm
gonna do this today and then it gets
away and
um nothing happens right yeah so
honestly it's having uh it feels weird
to say but it's having lower
expectations so that you can actually
achieve it and so
um here's what happens like when you
have really high expectations then when
you don't do it that you lose a little
more self-confidence and like every time
you say you're gonna do something and
then you don't do it you lose more
self-confidence yeah so then the next
time you say you're gonna do something
you're like yeah I'm probably not going
to do that either because you've kind of
trained yourself that when you say
you're gonna do something you don't
follow through yes yeah yeah or I have
like you know the plans there's the
plans like do all the home like take the
courses do all the homework on all the
courses and then the implementation
doesn't follow through you know in
so it's it's still having the vision
it's not like don't have a big vision
for your life and where you can go it's
like still having a vision for what you
could do and the impact you want to have
and the lives you want to change like
you're you're gearing towards some huge
thing that is impossible to do and
that's amazing like we're trying to
change the world and then today being
a lot smaller it's like okay my goal
like you showed up today this is great
and it was so last minute it was like
what two days I have to two days before
I get wet yeah but you could have said
hey I'm uh I'm not feeling well or I'm
not ready or I'm sick or I've got like
whatever like you could you could have
said that and we would have rescheduled
hey no problem Joy like we'll find but
you didn't and you're here yeah this is
a win right we're building yes yes
and so like feel that feel the feel the
joy of you showed up and you did it and
whether you have like the perfect
question or whatever like it started off
great we're looking at your computer
like how do I do this it's great
because I thought I was ready yeah yeah
like we're winning that that's the
process and so if every day you were
just to say okay tomorrow I've got blank
and I'm gonna this is what I'm gonna
show up for tomorrow
and then you actually do that thing so
yesterday is like okay tomorrow I'm
going to show up for the Instagram live
with Evan Carmichael and you did it and
that's a win and so we're celebrating
today and so tomorrow what's what's the
win that like think about what you have
to do or what you could do what is an
actual win for you for tomorrow
obviously because when I yeah that's a
really good question because immediately
I'm gonna build my website like start to
finish it's gonna be done which is like
it was a little bit high expectations
to build a brand new website start to
finish until it's done and perfect and
beautiful that's um that's uh that's a
project
I would love to have mine
done great joy
so that's great so just take that
concept and think of it like you're
gonna floss one tooth the goal is to
floss one tooth and if you show up and
you've lost one tooth cool like you hit
your goal
but you're probably going to do a little
bit more anyway yeah right like you're
probably not just gonna floss one tooth
you're probably going to floss a lot
more and maybe all of it so take that
website example cool so tomorrow is it
is it do you have time in your calendar
with your life and your health and the
family and you know everything that you
got going on do you have a block of time
tomorrow that you can focus on building
your website
yeah
cool what what time is reasonable for
you to work on the website I don't know
well let's Okay time time blocks aren't
easy like I just don't work in
I've tried to do that like this time
block I'm gonna do this I don't I need
to find another is there another way
there must be another way of organizing
a day instead of like time blocks when
time isn't something that I work
easily with
okay so you're gonna show up uh tomorrow
you've got some commitments I don't mean
life and morning routines or whatever
like you're gonna wake up at some point
maybe it's not consistent across every
day how do you decide what you're going
to do tomorrow you just wake up and say
I'm feeling what am I going to work on
like how do you how do you figure out
your dad
um generally well I always have a list
of too many things I want to get done
well we're going to fix that yeah sure
there's my bullet Journal there's the
list
um so yeah so there's an idea of the
things I want to get done so I wake up
do my morning routines and then
yeah I'm not really very good with
routines I mean I've gotten better doing
habits and consistently doing things but
I'm not really good with block time or
sitting down when I have a project even
if I have it written down it just kind
of falls out of my head of things I need
to be doing because something else comes
along oh look I need to take care of
that well we just need to simplify
especially at the beginning
just start building the new habits like
if you have never worked out going into
the gym and saying I'm going to list 800
pounds it's not gonna happen like you're
gonna break your back trying to do that
do you go in and you lose five pounds
you know four times and then you put the
weights down and tomorrow you show up
and you can carry a little bit more
right so yeah so tomorrow is it a crazy
day for you do you have a ton of
commitments or family or health things
you gotta you have a doctor's
appointment you have like there's
nothing no it's pretty open okay to what
I want to do mostly like every day
because I never knew what's gonna happen
Okay
so so having like a to-do list is great
you know like it helps you set some
priorities now it's moving it to an
action list so that tomorrow or even
maybe this afternoon you know is it are
you on the East Coast where are you I'm
in I'm on the west coast oh okay so it's
only it's 11 A.M for you right now yeah
it's early we still have time there's
time left today to do something so we
can even plan it for today instead of
tomorrow yeah you look at your to-do
list has a million things on it that all
need to get done and you and you want to
do them cool what one thing from that
to-do list could you move to an action
list that's going to happen today so if
it's website
underneath website is a million things
like there's tons of to figure and
finish your website it's not just a
bunch of text and throw it on a page and
you're done so inside website websites
on your to-do list what do we move to
our action list that you can do this
afternoon like what is a what is a
reasonable thing that once we're done
this call
we're going to take some action on our
website that you can actually complete
today that's the equivalent of flossing
one tooth it's just the first step
um
I think reading I I I've been a
WordPress person for a long time and
then it just instead of
WordPress getting easier it seemed to
have gotten more complicated over time
which seemed like oh I don't want to do
this anymore I wanted it to be easy
and so I found a web host that has a
drag and drop thing so I need to look at
the instructions okay the first what
what's what's the web host name
uh name cheat
so namecheap has a built-in web designer
that's drag and drop
cool so that's like that gets moved to
action list and the goal today is to
research and understand namecheaps
training
and maybe by the end of it you realize
name sheep is the best thing ever and
like wow this is so cool or maybe
realize well this sucks and it's
actually not as easy as I thought it was
going to be yeah
but so the goal of today like we have
our to-do list with a million things
awesome the action list for today is
figure out namecheap
yeah I have a backup plan to that
because I do have a lifetime for uh for
Divi and so namecheap also gives you the
option of having like the web hosting by
them or
doing whatever and so I do have Divi on
the background just in case but so the
goal today though is just figure out if
name cheat the the right option that's
it that's our goal yeah that's our
philosophy one truth and maybe you
figure that out in 20 minutes after
watching One training or maybe it takes
you three hours of going through it to
kind of figure it out but the idea is
this is the goal for the rest of the day
that if you hit that it's like hey pat
on the back like I said
a goal and I hit it I said I was gonna
do it and I did it
okay and if you complete that you can
always add more you can always
you know what I'm gonna try actually
building my website instead of just
researching I'm going to try just making
a home page and just playing around with
some text and maybe doing but it's not
the requirement
for the day
um okay
so we're lowering we still got a big
vision and big mission to what we can
accomplished we're lowering our
expectations for what we want to do
today because we don't want to train
ourselves that you set goals and then
don't follow through and then you feel
like you know you don't feel great
because you said you're going to do 10
things and you did like half of one
um
exactly yeah or I missed or missed any
any of my markers of doing any of the
things yeah
so like one that's the easiest way to
start building
momentum and rebuild your confidence is
one thing every day that you're going to
be working on towards building this
business for yourself and a realistic
like if you know that you're gonna you
have some wedding to go to tomorrow or a
doctor's appointment that's going to
take a chunk of your day or like don't
put some giant thing on when you know
there's some other crazy thing happening
for the day right right but if you know
your day is open even your your like
you're willing to take action because I
was saying tomorrow and he's like well I
got today he's like I love it
I could do today that's great let's go
today right and so it's just picking one
thing every day from to-do list to
action the to-do list is like the ideas
of the things that have to get done and
it's you've got your vision list of like
the world the big impact you want to
change in the world but a lot of that is
is like you don't have no idea how it's
going to happen the to-do list is
they're like okay these are some of the
steps that I think will work out but
then the action list is okay like today
here's what I'm working on or tomorrow
here's what I'm working on whatever kind
of flows best some people is better at
night to kind of figure out okay
tomorrow here's my one thing that I'm
going to focus on
or maybe for you it's the morning of
you know you're meditating or sitting in
the garden or sipping your coffee or
whatever he's like okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna work on this today whether it's
like night before or morning of to
decide just what's that one action that
you're gonna take today but then you're
going to celebrate yourself for instead
of beating yourself up for all the
things on your two lists that you like
didn't get done
yeah that that's familiar yes yes
um yeah that's a really good thing yeah
there's I do lots of other things but
the things that I want yes it's a matter
of getting the things that I want to get
done
um because I know I've heard you talk
and movement makers a lot about getting
on there doing the YouTube videos just
getting out there and speaking and I'm
like I did videos not my thing what are
you doing videos not your thing so that
kind of holds me back from doing video
when I feel like video is not my thing
um
what do you do then
well it's still content like what's your
message that you want to get out to the
world uh videos just the the most
prevalent because YouTube Instagram all
the platforms are going to video first
but you could still post content if you
love the written word maybe you start
crushing it on Twitter and you start
sharing your one-liners or your
inspiration maybe you take your
um you could take some pictures and put
it on Instagram with with a great copy
that go with each one it's still just
the idea of content creation
um but that doesn't necessarily have to
be like again build the baby steps to
build the foundation of confidence again
to teach yourself that you
you can get back to where you used to be
and more so don't stress out about like
I need now I need to
get my website done and I need to post
on Twitter and Instagram and take
pictures and write beautiful coffee
because then now we've made our action
as a giant and then and nothing happens
and then you stress out again over why
you can't do it right like yeah again
when I broke my neck I wasn't even
thinking about making content or my next
speaking gig or being behind and write
my book or I I mean I told everybody in
my life at the time like hey this
happened and I am not going to be as
responsible and I'm gonna drop a whole
bunch of balls and like I can't even
look at my phone or a screen for more
than five seconds because I have a
concussion like sorry guys I can't do
this right now and that's okay
and if if anybody's like well screw you
I need you to do it's like okay well
maybe you're not a good fit for how we
should be doing business together right
um and slowly I added more things back
in
um even in micro moments like that's a
major event uh and I don't know the
health issues that you went through but
it sounds like it was a pretty major
event it wasn't just like you got cold
and you're better the next day right
um but even in micro moments like
two nights ago I didn't sleep very well
and so
okay I gave myself a little more like a
little more grace for the day
but I don't I'm not gonna do as much
today because I'm gonna I'm gonna rest
because if I if I go crazy today and I
didn't sleep then I'm gonna I'm gonna
like really suffer tomorrow I might get
sick so it's micro adjustments too
sometimes when you need it not just like
big events when there's a Health crisis
or a family crisis or if somebody passes
away or something happens with your kids
or you know like all those things will
happen that might be major life changes
um but even in the micro like last night
I slept great
she's like let's go today come on we got
stuff to do let's go change the world
I'm excited come on let's add more to
the action list there's all the energy
from that yeah yeah yeah I mean sleep
matters a lot and but it's okay if like
last night
um I may not have as much energy if I
did sleep as well and I may not have and
that's okay
um
it's okay to have a little more grace
for yourself
um yeah
so yeah macro events that might change
you know like life-changing events might
be a little harder to bounce back from
that's okay and also the little micro
things that you know you have to bounce
back from that's okay like if something
happens
um and you didn't sleep as well but cool
can you still make a little bit of
progress on your website like can you
still
test out drag in and drop in a picture
in or put in some copy or looking up how
to how do I launch a Twitter account you
know if you don't have one or how do I
can I post one thing on Instagram today
and and it feels like nothing it feels
the problem is for Achievers it feels
like it's not enough
it's like I used to be able to do all
this stuff and now like the bar is so
low that I'm only like researching and
watching One video and seeing if that's
going to be a good website host for me
um but that's the process of rebuilding
confidence like it's better to do it's
better to over achieve on super small
goals than to underachieve on your big
goals because then it teaches you that
you won't follow through the next time
yeah yeah that's a really valid point I
think when I was so I have multiple
chemical sensitivity which means that
um like somebody's laundry or yep
exhaust bars or like and Myriad of
things right so neighbor's laundry
starts doing their laundry and the
exhaust from their vent comes out it's
like everybody runs around the house and
closes all the windows and by that point
it's like where's my you know causes
brain fog and then well I can't really
do very much with a whole lot of brain
fog and I'm doing a lot better now but
sometimes like yesterday I was just
taken right out and I was literally
paralyzed while in the park because
something happened yeah came by and I'm
like well what do I do now I can't go
anywhere literally so it's like so
that's why I don't plan anything because
it's just I just never know
so listen so something like that like I
I do too I had um Alex on my team he
helps me run Toronto Dan salsa came over
on Monday and he had really strong
cologne on for whatever reason and I'm I
walk upstairs he's in my kitchen it's
like holy cow I cannot like for most
people it's not a big deal I guess but I
couldn't breathe I could not breathe so
we had our meeting but I sat at my patio
with the window open like in front of
the screen with just freezing cold air
on me just to get fresh air and like a
blanket and a heat pad
for us to have the meeting and then he
went home afterwards it's like don't
work here because that's like we'll
still have our meeting I need Fresh Air
Blast into my face and for most people
it's like that's not a big deal it's
just a little bit of cologne but for me
it's like I couldn't concentrate like
can't I'm getting a headache in eight
seconds so so we adjusted you know
around that and then he went home and
you know he's like next time hopefully
he doesn't wear a really strong cologne
when he's like I gotta put a sign on my
door like the doctor's office like don't
wear no strong perfumes or cologne
um
him him sit outside and you're inside
right that should have been that it
doesn't stay in your house because it's
staying in your house otherwise that is
the point I love it Alex I need to send
him this video so that hopefully next
time he doesn't even wear anything
um well let him know yeah yeah you know
he definitely knows
like if you're not you're not gonna
follow through on something
then you have to be proud of the reason
why I feel like that's the key so you
say you're gonna you're gonna work on
your website today and if you don't then
you have to be proud of the reason why
it's like okay but like the the exhaust
went off and I was on the floor for half
the day so I couldn't do it as long as
like nobody else can let you off the
hook
you know it's if you're if you're okay
with the reason why then then it's okay
then you don't lose your confidence you
know if like I'm proud of how I did that
thing without I'm still gonna have this
meeting I'm gonna suffer I'm going to be
cold I'm going to have a blanket and a
heat pad on me and my dogs on me warming
me up and we're still having this
meeting like that's how I I'll feel
confident about myself that I said I was
gonna do it and we're gonna do it I
could have been smarter I could have
sent him outside that's a much better
solution Joey than what I came up with
but like at least in my head to myself I
still did it we still had the meeting we
still made progress right
um if if he knocked me out like if if I
couldn't find a solution and just that's
it I'm done for the day that's okay I
mean I had I don't know seven other
meetings afterwards and if I had to
cancel on them because I couldn't show
up then I would tell them guys I like I
can't focus right now I'm no good to you
in a meeting I need to
sit outside or meditate or nap or cold
shower or whatever and I'm okay with the
reason why it's not because I'm not
motivated or I don't believe I can it's
like I'm physically unable to do this
thing so as long as you're proud of the
reason why you're not doing it it's not
because you're overthinking or over
planning you just physically can't do
the thing because that situation
happened and kind of Knocked you on the
ground that's okay
I'm feeling much better after talking
with you because
I'm doing this like I feel like I do
this alone in my own yeah just alone
because there's a lot of isolation
because I can't go anywhere but you know
like just literally alone all the time
like with this oh yeah I can't do this
and I can't do that and
it's discouraging but I'm feeling one
thing and yeah that just being
um
just like what you said about being
proud of the reason it's like it's okay
I if I can't do that right now you know
I remember I was on I was visiting the
city and uh I went into a bookstore it
was like a super old bookstore like
really really old book and the dust was
insane and I've got crazy dust allergies
and so I was walking through there and I
started sneezing and I I try to just
stay with my wife who like for whatever
reason I don't know how she didn't
notice or like she wasn't suffering at
all like what anyway and then like that
ruined my entire afternoon just sneezing
and the sneezing lets a giant headache
and I couldn't focus on anything it's
like okay I can't keep going around the
city and and so it's fine like I
physically can't go off and do it that's
okay uh but not because I don't want to
or I'm not capable of you know like I'm
just overthinking over planning
um and now I have a better strategy for
next time like as soon as I go into a
into a store and it smells crazy Dusty
I'm out like you go you spend as much
time as you in their brows peruse
don't feel like I'm holding you back
spend two hours in there if you want I'm
gonna sit outside and do something else
because that's gonna cause some crazy
chaos for me
um
so you get better strategies but you
know in the moment if that happens then
it's okay to let yourself it's not like
letting yourself off the hook but let
yourself
um you know again you're proud of the
reason why it's okay like you're
physically not able to do it instead of
beating yourself up yeah it's honoring
where we're at instead of feeling like
you know feeling dismissive or angry or
you know berating because oh well I
guess I'm not you know fill in the blank
good enough worthy and you know whatever
um
yeah
yeah
exactly
it's accessible now everybody uses masks
you know you have better Solutions than
me this is great you know
I wish I thought of that uh I I suffered
and struggled walking through there you
know I didn't I didn't want to make a
scene I didn't want to make them make
you know them feel bad or whatever but
meanwhile I'm suffering and struggling
that's so hard and then your eyes start
watering and you're like it's like once
it gets to my headache and like I can
deal with physical pain of sneezing and
it's annoying or whatever but once you
like are holding your sneeze so much
that then yeah the headache then that's
where like crazy migraine issues growing
up uh that's when it gets hard to focus
it's like I can't I can't see the screen
I can't
how am I supposed to do a blank right
and so yeah that's okay like at that
point okay it's okay maybe the whole day
is gone and you start again tomorrow
maybe you just need a two hour break
maybe you just need to close your eyes
and and meditate or wash your face out
or neti pot or like you know maybe you
come back to it or maybe not but as long
as you're proud of the reason why like
you did your best you tried
it's not for lack of effort there's
there's an actual
legitimate like physical reason why you
can't do the thing
yeah yeah for sure oh I'm feeling so
much better after this talk I love it
okay before before we close what's
what's the quote on your wall behind you
um it says life is it life isn't
measured by the number of breaths we
take but by the moments that take our
breath away
I like it which is great if you don't
have like something in your room with
cologne and you can't breathe yeah well
true then it's measured by how many
breaths that I'm taking
well thank you Joey thank you for the
love thank you for being part of
movement makers and um happy looking at
your website today I'm excited for you
hey coach another entrepreneur one on
one check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there it's a
different kind of strategy than most
it's not the I need to get a million
subscribers on my channel it's getting
the right people on your show so you can
build your business sell it and then
build your other business overseas